jonathan taylor thomas was just
photographed in los angeles for what
seems to be the first time
in nearly eight years so if you're
sitting around wondering whatever
happened to the 90s heartthrob
i've got an update for you how's mom
not too bad she finally stopped saying
boys whatever you do
don't turn out to be like your father
check out the former home improvement
star dressed in a new york mets hat
sunglasses a dark hoodie jeans and new
balance sneakers
walking two dogs and holding on to his
phone
he's certainly grown up since his days
playing randy taylor opposite
tim allen on the beloved 90s sitcom the
response was
know really great and pretty
overwhelming the 39 year old actor was
last seen on tv
when he reunited with his home
improvement dad on allen's more recent
sitcom
last man standing hey mike baxter hey
andy look familiar
jtt was in four episodes of the series
between 2013
and 2015 and also directed three
episodes
before that he hadn't been on tv since a
2005 appearance on veronica mars
i didn't read it i thought maybe i'd
wait for the mini series
of course in the 90s and early 2000s
thomas was a household name
but he decided to step away from the
spotlight as he grew up
you know it feels good to know that you
know everything that you put into it
you know the people like it in 2000 he
graduated with honors from high school
and enrolled at harvard where he studied
philosophy
and history he spent his third year
abroad at st
andrews university in scotland and in
2010
thomas graduated from columbia
university school of
general studies and while he's been
flying under the radar his tv mom
patricia richardson
told et last year that she talks to him
all the time
specifically about getting more involved
with the sag-aftra actors union
when jonathan was first on the show and
i knew how smart he was
um i would say what do you want to do
when you grow up
and he would say i don't know i don't
know maybe maybe i'll be a politician i
said you should be president of the
united states
and he was like well you know i kind of
think about it sometimes and so
cut two years later and i'm doing all
this work at the union
i mean you really need to get more
younger actors involved in this union
and so i called up jonathan
i said what do you think about um
running with us
so he's been on the national board with
me now and he is everybody
even the other side is impressed with
jonathan i mean the thing is
jonathan kind of like me both of us were
very press shy
and we didn't really like being famous
neither one of us did
also last year et spoke with devin sawa
who co-starred in the 1997 family movie
wild america with thomas
you know what that sound is hundreds of
sleeping bears ready to wake up and tear
faces off
sawwa shared that he spoke with jtt not
long ago about a possible project
that never took off a mockumentary style
show with their fellow former child star
macaulay culkin
they were going to see if uh if i would
be involved in it it was going to be
like a kind of a mockumentary
tv show where where we are now but just
like
not really us you know what i mean like
almost like a curb your enthusiasm
it was good to speak to him you know
he's uh
i always knew that i always i always had
a feeling that
um from doing school with him that he
was going to go off and do things other
than acting
because he was just so smart and
so to find out he went off to harvard
and
took a different road was not surprising
but i'm
you know he's i miss him he's a good guy
you